hello everyone this is samir from audio
science review
uh we're going back to school again uh
this time on a
topic that's becoming news around my
neck seems like every other day
i do a review somebody complains about
me listening too loud or testing
speakers and
and uh headphones too loud and
uh there's actually a lot to this topic
and much of it seems to be unknown given
the fact that
many people get this wrong and this is
not unique to
people in one camp or the other i find
both camps whether you're objectivism
subjectivists
get all this wrong including reviewers
and
and people claim to know the topic but
in my opinion clearly do not so i
thought i'd make a powerpoint
presentation
uh i was hoping that once i left the
corporate world i would never touch
powerpoint again
here i am i don't know how else to
convey this topic and keep it in some
kind of organized fashion so
here we go i've called it music how loud
is loud
let's start with what i call
prosecutions
exhibit one and this actual comment
somebody made when i uh posted a review
of the hi-fi man
ananda a couple days ago and
uh he the literal comment was if you're
listening 94 db
you need to get your ears checked and
it's a shorthand notation to what people
typically
say if you push them on where you get
that number they go to
various workplace safety standards as
far as noise
in u.s that's a part of the osha
government standards setting a body
that's uh
sets uh limits for industrial noise
exposure
that employ
employers have to follow otherwise it
could be subject to litigation and and
uh
fines and what have you and
they usually go look bring up this table
this this individual did not
and then they point to various things in
here like i
run a test at 114 db spl and they
quickly say oh you're going to go deaf
in 15 minutes
and even at higher limits you know let's
say
lower limits let's say 105 db spl um
you know it says oh only one hour
clearly we don't listen to music for
just one hour we may listen seven eight
hours
uh you know this this must be a terrible
thing
um i should point out that the 94 db spl
comes in my testing for headphones
in from my calibration of my headphone
texture
headphone fixture i'll have a specific
instrument that generates a tone at 94
db very accurately and you put it in the
fixture
and then you measure the microphone
voltage and you match the two
and that is what my fixtures calibrated
as
therefore it's most accurate that that
that setting is probably almost as good
at other ones but i know for sure that
94 db
is properly calibrated as far as spl
um and then that gets us to this graph i
was just talking about the 94 104 114
where did these three numbers come from
94 i just explained which is my uh
reference uh test for frequency response
i also picked this because it's loud
enough that overrides the room noise
where i'm measuring headphone
especially open back headphones kind of
letting room noise in there
and you want your signal to be
substantially 30 to 40 db
above the room noise so that when you
measure frequency response and
distortion what have you
the error is well below one percent
there so i have 94 db and that's where
that 94 comes from there's no
industry standard of you know what you
measure frequency response at so i have
to pick something
um i have a nice situation that i've
used a topping a 90
headphone amplifier and has three gain
switches and each one of them is
separated by 10 db so all i've got to do
to measure 140b is just flip a switch
and then
114 i flip the switch again and the key
with that is that i don't have to muck
with the volume control and lose my
setting
so i just flip a switch three different
ways and capture three
settings and like this uh abyss
diana v2 headphone you can see that
there's
three levels of of uh measurements to be
made i'm just showing you the uh
the distortion graph in here people
immediately zoom into what is 114 and
say
why the heck are you measuring at 114 i
never ever listen to
114. heck i don't listen at 104 or even
94. i listen at 70 db
75 maybe 80 db none of this matters to
me
so this is all bogus and you must not
know what you're doing
well i think i know what i'm doing but
let's continue and let me demonstrate
that to you
so how loud is loud um
this is actually a larger topic that's
been researched a fair bit
into what kind of dynamic range do we
need in our systems
to reproduce basically a live event
everybody's dream of hi-fi
is that it replace takes you you know as
if you were listening to a concert
or or a live performance and you want to
bring that home right that is the
ultimate vision of what a hi-fi system
should do
so luis uh fielder that uh
worked at dolby he's an aes fellow
uh he was also a president of audio
engineering society for a few years
i wrote a couple of very intensively
research papers
uh their peer review their part of the
journal of audio engineering society
not to be confused with the conference
papers uh
the journal papers have to be really
authoritative and and detailed
uh there's no automatic that is right
but you know
you know it's gotta feel good to a bunch
of other uh
peers of that person that this this
brexit new ground as far as information
is
sharing and he's written at least two
papers maybe three that
dig into this topic of how what is the
the two extremes that we need to
represent in in
music what's the loudest that we want to
have what's the quietest we want to have
and once you have those two numbers that
differential tells you the dynamic range
you need
and if you just and that gives you a db
value if you divide by six
you'll get the number of bits you need
uh on this so it's a very useful thing
and dolby obviously is interested in
this from
excuse me movie soundtracks and what
have you the paper is old as you can see
from the typeface so yeah this was
probably 10 or 20 years ago 20 years ago
maybe it came out
on this thing so he starts off with with
going back say all right what is what is
the live performance how loud is the
live performance and inside some of the
early work that other people had done
not as exacting it
as he's done and uh very surprising
information for example he's
you know there was the researcher by the
name of civilian
and just two pianos uh playing
the uh spl was was peak svl was 103 to
104 db
so those of you who say ah less than 70
db it's like a piano is not a
drum it's it's what people think i mean
people actually listen to it know that
it can get quite loud but to a lay
person
you know thinks ah the piano is nothing
else you know it's not very loud
i can get very loud he also researched a
15-piece orchestra that was 112 db spl
uh on this thing another study over here
uh
they came up with numbers of 114 or 122
dv
for classical and popular music so you
can see there's some kind of consensus
building up
these numbers are not in 70 80 db um
then there were some tests done in in
recording studios
um and that was between 111 180 db spl
and i tell you i've been to uh major
labels and and
uh but when they play uh in their mixing
rooms and
master rooms they probably quite loud uh
it's not like what you think just
background you know
uh music on this thing so um this was
the following
of that same paragraph you know you can
see that it goes as high as 125 db
spls uh different recording locations
now lewis tried to actually set up his
own
test and there's two versions of this
this is the more extensive one
like i said there's another earlier
paper and uh
that he found that the measures that
he measured as much as 122 db for
classical 124
db spl uh for this electronically
augmented country music
and i'll show you the the second test
that he did where that wasn't the case
so he went and surveyed 47 different uh
basically live presentations and this is
not him
showing up standing in middle of the
stage and measuring
he actually sits in the rows and
actually tells you row six or whatever
that
in what theater is adding and uh oh
concert hall he said in and uh
he he measured this using a special peak
detection uh
spl meter which i'll talk about uh later
on and uh
you can see the range of numbers in here
um rock music obviously you know can get
pretty loud
uh 115 db to 129 db spl
but jazz music for example 127 db for
jazz
uh so this is not some heavy metal rock
and roll
you know music where people are just
going deaf in there you know it's what
people think
you know sort of adult music and uh it's
quite loud
so he has this histogram over here of
all the different uh venues and how many
of them were at what
level and the ones in black are actually
are uh
unamplified that means just the
instruments themselves producing sound
so people think oh yeah but massive pa
speakers and arrays
you know you can you know crank that
level to anything you want and indeed
those
do capture the highest levels over here
electronic augmentation
but with no amplification you can see
that we have
a number of the venues we want to easily
land in 120 125 db spl
in here so you know if you look at down
here he
is nothing below 90 i mean it just goes
left over here
a lot of these if you look at the where
the distribution is is between 105
115 db spl so uh
quite loud again these are real people
listening in the real seating location
uh
in a live venue of all different kinds
of
of music and these are the levels that
he found so
for sure you know forget about this
concept of oh i'm listening 70 80 db
i guarantee you you don't have a concept
of loudness or db when you
say numbers like that um
he goes on then as i mentioned he
defines the peak and then he also
defines the floor
and some many of you probably familiar
with fletcher munson
um equal contour
uh hearing or loudness level curves this
is the lowest one in theirs called the
hearing threshold and it basically says
that
if you take the frequency and you play a
sine wave
uh the the lowest level sine wave that
people can hear
follows this curve so it is not at all a
flat line that we think
frequency response is our hearing is
pretty bad
at 20 hertz it requires 65 db just to
hear
20 hertz 65 decibels so when you tell me
you listen at 70 db
that means you're not ever hearing 20
hertz it's only 5 db above
threshold it just is nothing but the
same 65 db
here at 2 or 3 kilohertz is about 70 db
above your threshold or hearing so
frequency matters
your hearing is extremely non-linear
with respect to this
now know that when music screen created
a human being also sat there
and evaluated loudness with the same
ears that you have
so this curve has been built into the
music and it builds
into the your hearing as well so in a
way it is a flat perceived curve
but in reality the the hearing follows
this kind of curve so when the
person is mixing mastering music he is
creating bass that goes way above 65 db
uh for it to be heard otherwise let's
say it's at 50 db
it's not it's totally silent so he
clearly is not going to
she's not going to clear music create
music that
has you know you can't hear so turn it
up listen to it and therefore the base
content which i'll show you in a minute
will definitely definitely be a lot
louder than it is
in in in this range okay so
this is a good paper if you want to go
find it and basically he builds a case
saying that look
you know the lowest level we want is
around zero below
zero db and if the maximum is 122 db or
125 db
we basically need about 21 bits of
dynamic range
to have a silent noise floor and be able
to create
a live music venues
sound level in our channel so anything
below 21db
what we call flat pcm encoded is is
going to have noise floor that's audible
or it can't get that loud but that's fun
of the topic
and i've got an article on that i'll
reference later on for you
so so we've got this background of
of what is real what is the real db
what is what are peak levels and i'll
talk about p versus average
a little bit later um so but what is all
these noise standards i mean clearly if
if you're sitting there listening to
music uh there's no
police there showing up saying whoa all
of these people
listen to this concert jazz concert or
two piano is gonna go deaf
uh after an hour or two of that and and
why isn't there why isn't there articles
and
all that saying hey any kind of live
music is gonna make you go deaf
there isn't but i'll talk about why
there is and why they're completely
different domains people usually cite
this osha standard which i talked about
a little bit bigger picture over here
and they have this graph and
you can see by 100 db is getting into
this yellow range and boom by
120 db is you know well into the red
zone first of all what is this number
you look at it in here it doesn't say db
spl so dba
the a means is a weighted what is a
weighted means
it means you capture the the sound in
the environment
and you apply a filter to it a frequency
response shaping to it
and you throw out a bunch of stuff and
what comes out is what you measure as
one number by the way not a sequence of
numbers for different frequencies
but only a single number so what does a
weighting look like if you go to
wikipedia
uh you see that this light blue curve is
the a weighting
so you take the let's say the noise is
out there it's
uniform you know at 0 db you
run it through a software hardware that
chops off basically all the low
frequencies
look at how much at 20 hertz is chopping
up 50 decibels
and then at one kilohertz two kilohertz
three kilos it doesn't chop off anything
and then at high frequency starts to
chop off some of it again
why does it do that because remember
this is inverse of our hearing
what i was showing in fletcher munson
curves and
fielders threshold of hearing it's
because they recognize that we don't
hear
low frequencies that well so our hearing
naturally is a filter
of of low frequencies it takes a ton of
low frequencies for us to be able to
hear that therefore why put significance
on that one
clearly it's not going to be an audible
thing
it's not going to be something that
damages our hearing so
when my measurements are provided
they're all raw they're all
db spls that means there's no weighting
applied to it
uh you can't compare the weighted versus
unweighted measurements they're
completely different animals
especially in low frequencies as i
mentioned so
in here again 50 decibels is filtered
out before the government says
you know this let's measure to see how
bad this is so
this becomes quite important and i'll
show you that again
if you look at my headphone measurements
you see this preference curve and ignore
this boost for now you can see that it's
sort of in blue it curves up and curves
down
why because our hearing our ears and ear
canals
are resonant chambers and they amplify
certain range of frequencies
and they're most sensitive in this sort
of a two to five kilohertz or one to
five kilohertz
down here sensitivity goes down and you
can see what a difference
it makes it in that it goes way down so
you don't want loud sounds in this
region because
the ear then amplifies it again and
subjects it to your
hearing system and you could damage the
hair sales and and cause
nerve damage so you don't want to
and this is the area that's danger zones
and that's what the government cares
about basically a waiting says let's
chop all this down
way down here so loudness in this area
is not something that the government
cares about
the safety standards care about they
care about myth frequencies they also
don't care about
extreme highs as much but certainly they
don't care about the base frequencies
so that brings us to a
major punchline in that when we when
music is created
it always follows this kind of this
exponential curve
where all the energy is in the base
most of the energy is in the base and
then gradually
declines to you get higher and higher
now
on purpose i once picked an instrumental
track this chris jones has no sanctuary
this used to be the
demo track it's very well recorded uh 20
years ago it got overplayed and doesn't
get played anymore
but uh going and look it up on youtube
or or if you have
subscription music you know look it up
it's a delightful track
and and it's an instrumental thing it's
in strings it's a male vocal
so i didn't go pick some heavy metal
tracks or techno what have you
picked an instrumental sort of a adult
music if you will
and you can look in here and say at 30
hertz
the relative level is 20 db below the
maximum that
we could have zero db digital but then
as you go get to one kilohertz we're
already down
40 decibels so if you
you know the government cares about how
loud something is at one kilohertz
if you take that same loudness you're
allowed to have 40 db more in base
so if the government says hey 90 db is
as high as i want you to go
at one kilohertz that means actually
saying hey the base can be 130 db and
that's cool too
so keep that in mind that the energy and
music
is in this base area it is not now you
intuitively you should know that you
look at the driver sizes in your
speakers
the woofer's giant and the twitter is
little thing right the woofer is moving
in and out massively the twitter you
can't even see it move
so it should make sense that the energy
and music
is in bass yet the safety standards
don't care about bass loudness they care
about the mid to high frequency loudness
we actually care a lot about bass
because bass represents 30 percent of
the
fidelity that uh consumers our listeners
assigned to the overall sound of the
system
so super important to us but it's not
super important to the uh
people who care about uh hearing
protection
now this is a big confusion of
difference between
peak and average loudness they're
completely different animal
animals when you look at music you know
a drum gets hit
all sudden you get a spike and that
spike is could be just two or three
milliseconds
it doesn't last a whole second doesn't
last the whole hour doesn't last
30 minutes now somebody going and
working the factory floor
and there's a machine that's cranking
it just that noise floor is constant
listen to a washing machine at your
house or
or the fan in addition in a microwave
oven or what have you those are constant
levels of noise
that just continuously go on music is is
impulsive
meaning that we have peaks and the peaks
last so little that
there is no safety standards for one
millisecond of anything now i don't take
this
extreme but i'm pretty sure if i played
one millisecond at 140 db you just do
this and
be done your hair is not going to get
you know uh damaged in just that one
millisecond
uh on this thing so now
this also then let's talk about how do
you measure something like this
the way you do not measure it is by spl
meter
you cannot measure it with splunk spl
meters integrate things over time
and they also have their own frequency
response worst thing is they go get a
phone like this
you don't even know what the microphone
frequency response on this thing is how
accurate any of that is
and the day rate they're way way way too
slow
um as i mentioned in the fielder's
research he actually built his own peak
detection
svl meter and that's what he used to
find those numbers
if you had gone into the same venue with
your phone and turned it on
you'd get 10 or 20 db 30 db lower values
because
uh their peaks and they have the lowest
amounts are getting average together
and you just get you're not getting a
sense of what the peak amplitude is
so you may have thought you were in a
music concert listen to jazz music and
it was
90 db but in reality the peaks maybe in
110 120
on that okay um
the uh i've actually written a paper on
on
how you determined uh what is wrong with
an spl meter for
purposes of setting a dynamic range
which i talked about in in the
research paper if you're interested i'll
put it i'll put this in the description
to
to go and read it's a nice summary of
the paper and
and talks about high resolution audio
and and the
considerations there but anyway
there are ways to measure this uh but
requires fair bit of knowledge in what
you're doing
and uh one of our kind members uh goes
by the name of zelda dude
he actually runs a site called diy audio
haven
and he has tons of headphone
measurements and good articles he's an
electrical engineer practicing one
and he set out to actually measure
um the uh average to peak
of of common music he just grabbed a
piece of music and i forget
uh was a tracy chapman or some common
you know pop music track and he listened
to it
at different levels and then took a 10
second section of that music
and quantifies what that level is as far
as loudness both
subjectively and as far as peak and
average spls
so he grabbed this part of it and he was
listening at what he called
comfortably loud uh that's
to me that's that's what i like you're
enjoying it but you
know that your ears are not suffering
there you're
turning it up you're enjoying the music
you're not listening to his background
music while you're doing other work
you're enjoying it
in that he measured a 90 db average
and a peak of 102 db
not 70 db not 80 db 102 decibels
was comfortably loud yet when i showed
you the start of the presentation
somebody told me if i'm listening to 90
40
i need to have my hearing checked this
is basically 90 db
is listening and he's not going deaf and
he actually goes through when
when he gets uncomfortable i think it
was like 112 or something is when he got
uncomfortable
um and then he goes whereas faint on
this thing so
absolutely you can't you know run by
those numbers you do i
my first question when people tell me
you know that's too loud is how did you
measure
your headphones how do you know how loud
you're listening to
and the way you do that you measure the
voltages and in this case you use the
storage scope and the storage scope has
these nice meters where it captures the
peak voltages
in this case is put in the cursor at the
peak voltage that it detected
and then he's able to use that both the
peak and rms value is shown in near
voltages
he then takes those and using the
efficiency of that
headphone which uh tile had measured the
inner fidelity i think it was an hd 650
headphone
and converted that to db and
you know tiles efficiency numbers you
know is
approximate um but it's good enough for
this kind of analysis at least
uh on this thing so a real practical
example
great work done you can go in here and
check it out and uh he's one of the
people when i go in and correct people
that this stuff's not too loud
he always kindly points out that that's
the case also
um one of the interesting things that at
94 db spl
i can actually wear the headphone on my
ears and hear the sweep
a bass is barely loud on that
the mid to highs get a little bit
uncomfortable but
i can listen to it because the sleep is
like one and a half seconds it's like
which
is done he actually won repeated that
exercising came back and reported said
yep you can listen you can listen 94 db
and
you know you don't go deaf so now let's
uh you know skin this guy another
direction thx
used to be a very big name in in home
theaters not as much of a
brand these days but back in the day it
was and thx has set up some
certification levels for
how loud and how much dynamic range
products need to have
their businesses home theater focused
and there for the speakers and
amplifiers it says that you have to be
able to play an
average of 85 vv but have 20 db of
headroom
which means that you need to be able to
produce 105 db spl
and anything is thx certified needs to
be able to do this and you find
basically commodity products that are
capable of having this certification on
them
for the subwoofer which is what we care
about why i do a lot of my measurements
in low frequencies
um actually these 115 db spl
is what is required to get the
certification you can have more
but that's the minimum that they require
on this thing
so that again proves that we can
tolerate
the sub base a lot higher norway would
thx have a certification
program that would cause manufacturers
to build a cope and accounts people to
go deaf right that liability for that
would be huge
so clearly clearly p you know
there's they understand the topic and
there's a distinction between peak
of a 115 db versus an average of 85 db
so here they basically say you can have
30 db of
of dynamic range uh or peak headroom
on this thing now
one of the key things key reasons are
measure
at three different levels it isn't for
frequency response because you could
just have one of them
but looking at distortion as a trend uh
because a lot of times we go
in there and we want to boost the
low frequencies uh harman's research
has shown that preference that people
have in headphones
is to not only have flat response they
actually have elevated bass
and i find that in sub-bass area
it is essential to get a great sensation
out of headphones that you actually
cannot get out of speakers speakers give
you
a mechanical feel which is wonderful but
to have a
speaker or even with a sub that's flat
to 20 hertz
it's extremely hard whereas with
headphones hey i could have a hundred
dollar headphone that goes flat to 20
hertz
or even above flat at 20 hertz so
since we can't have that might as well
get it but what you don't want to do is
have a ton of distortion that goes with
that or
clipping or crackling and what have you
one of the tests i've done
slip it up work i don't always do it is
that i measure distortion
pre-equalization and then post
equalization
so here i did it with this focal clear
you can see the baseline is this blue
line here so that's just measuring
itself
and here you can see there's only point
five percent distortion
but the moment i equalize it just a few
db
notice that it shoot if i don't allow
headroom for now if we ignore the vi 5-1
look at how much distortion shoots up
all of a sudden goes from half db
shoots up to 12 i mean half a percentage
to
12 percentage uh distortion
so how do you know that this could
happen well you look at
if i go to the uh first this is the kind
of graph that tells you that
if you notice on here when i'm playing
94 the
distortion is way down here but when i
add 10 more db
you know distortion jumps this much but
i had 10 more
after that all sudden distortion goes
through the roof so you can predict
how much equalization you have to do
whether you land from
infinity you go from this graph to to
the red one or you're gonna go into this
green one
so a lot of times when i do headphone
reviews when i see this third curve
is under control and i say hey that's a
good thing that means
you can add a lot of equalization and
still not have
noticeable problems in there
so continuing on
um a lot of the comments that i get is
sort of
personal in that people trying to take a
jab at me
both from point of view of oh i know
more than you do and
oh wait a second you don't seem to know
anything
why do you have to test these things
this way
but step back say i see my job in being
the most critical
user of equipment there is and
an analyzer of equipment i need to be
able to have stressful enough
measurements and listening tests where i
can separate even two excellent products
i don't want to say well there's a
hundred products that are all just as
good as each other
what's the point of that i devi i devise
both listening tests and measurements
where i can tease out differences there
in any product that you know i come at
it from different angles
and i want to find those uh cracks
in there now 99 of you may not
push the thing as hard but the one
percent of you that do
i want to be able to represent your
views as well last thing i want to do is
recommend the product
and you come back and say hey wait a
second when i listen to my favorite
music
i'm hearing this distortion you didn't
say anything about distortion in there
so all right well i need to then be able
to test that so when i'm listening to a
headphone
i uh crank up the volume for like a
second or two and say hey
what is happening to the bass can i hear
that distortion that i measure
how audible is that distortion i crank
it up and i'm like
got really bad turning down or i crank
it up i'm like wow there's no distortion
it sounds great so
my listening tests are designed for that
kind of thing i
heavily value my hearings because that's
my job this is what i do right now it's
my hobby
so please don't go make an astonished
remark that oh
you know this guy is blowing his
eardrums and i'm not going to listen to
him ever
he must be deaf by now no i you know i'm
able to beat many people
in control blind test because i do
protect my hearing and i
i know the damage that this can cause
maybe
you know 10 years from now i'll regret
doing this a little bit one or two
second testing also
um but you know i do turn it up um
when i'm listening to music myself i'm
not in testing mode
uh i listen to music six seven hours a
day and there i'm listening at
background level music while i'm working
with my headphones
and then also now i land on the track in
my uh
title subscription and i'm like hey that
sounds good crank it up yeah that sounds
good you know you're enjoying that and
then
turn it back down and your ears will
tell you that hey
you know it's getting too loud getting
too annoying turn it down so
please separate out what i do for you
all versus what i do myself is
it's quite insulting to have people come
back and say well you know you must
be so dumb to be listening at loud music
all the time
that's not what i do um
one key thing is that it's very hard to
know what these distortion numbers mean
so how audible is this uh what
i mean shows you the distortion from
half a percent up to 12
was it a terrible thing i have to listen
if i don't listen
who's going to listen you all going to
want to go test that hypothesis
no it's my job to do that comparison so
i turn on the eq and i turn on the
volume and say hey
you know did i hear any distortion or
did i not if i didn't well then eq is
good if
i hear distortion then i'll pull the eq
down even though from tonality point of
view i may have needed that much space i
said no that's just getting too
distorted
or it's getting too bright i gotta pull
that down
a great example came up tonight um
oh this should say e-like so let me fix
it before i
uh yep um
i've got a second example of this focal
elex
and uh was listening to it and
uh i just was listening to the normal
volume and all of a sudden i hear the
left speaker left
headphone cup starting to crackle a
little bit and i went up a little bit
more and the right one did
and this is with eq turned on so bass
has been boosted
and i'll tell you it just was not loud
music yes it was deep bass and yes i'd
eq that it was just normal
in a good level of listening but i
thought well shoot if i just say that
you're all going to come back and say
uh you know many people have been saying
the mighty you know
[ __ ] out clear or he likes doesn't do
this and therefore you must be listening
at
you know 20 to be higher and then you go
and death but i happen to have my son
here who's
in his 20s and very sensitive hearing
much better than mine and i had him
listen
and uh his report was the same his
crackling is clicking and to him the
sound was not
loud no he wouldn't listen for hours and
hours at that level but he didn't at all
think that hey this is
you know you're listening way too loud
before clicking happens so the crackling
was happening and uh it's a problem he
said
you know and you know i've seen just a
bare mention of it in some reviews of
of this uh series of headphones from
focal
i think that's that's not right we need
to highlight these problems
so the company knows about it and even
if they don't acknowledge it i'm sure
they read these things
eventually and the next generation will
have these problems result
you know no headphone costing nearly a
thousand dollars should just crackle as
you turn up the volume on
what i consider typical audio file
listening levels
and the fact that you can't hear it
because you have the same headphone
means nothing i don't understand why
people
keep saying well i've got one of these
and i don't hear i'm not great
but i don't know if you have the same
headphone sample as i
have i don't know what music you listen
to sure i don't know how loud you're
listening to because you don't know how
to measure it
at all so telling me that you don't hear
it doesn't invalidate the fact that i as
a critical tester
can hear it can validate it and can
stand behind this observation that this
is a fatal flaw
in a near fatal flaw for this whole
series of headphones
uh i would have given these headphones
highest marks possible
but you know when a headphone crackles i
don't care how good the tonality or
resolution is once you crackle you're
out of the running
on that thing so it's not a headphone
that i would buy personally uh for that
reason so i'm hoping there's a focal
version too or whatever
they decide to call it so long
presentations let me
bring us to the end let me start with
something i didn't talk a lot about
absolutely protect your hearing nothing
about this presentation is about
convincing you to listen louder
you obviously listen to whatever is
enjoyable level for you
and that's fine and and indeed losing
your hearing is a terrible thing
you can't get it back maybe in the
future there's some research that helps
us but
with both age and loud exposure you can
damage your hearing
so but please don't make up empty
arguments that shows that you don't you
haven't researched and i haven't
understood the topic whatsoever
do not throw safety standards as people
for enjoying music
safety standards have waiting in them
they're designed for continuous
obnoxious uh factory floor noise or
machinery it is not for music it's you
never see those people going giving
tickets to the
concert goers saying you know or whoever
owns a concert venue that they're making
people go deaf
it just isn't the same animal yes if
you're dealing with pure noise
you know car engine noise what have you
you go by that but
with respect to music it is not in the
same domain do not be fooled with
spl in one place and spl another um
in my opinion listening in moderation to
loud music is fine i mean uh when i go
to a concert this loud
uh wear earplugs so i actually keep my
fingers in there if i don't have
earplugs and
i try to stay in the back or something
so i do you know
there are crazy you know situations
where you can damage your hearing but
when i'm listening to my system when i
have volume control
you know beautiful well-recorded music
comes up it's got good bass good
dynamics i turn it up that's what being
an audiophile is
if you're just listening to elevated
music levels that's not being audiophile
you may be a music lover but you're not
an audiophile naughty fob
has gotten a great system with great
dynamic range great capability and wants
to have
realistic presentation yeah crank it up
uh on this thing um know that with
basically
loudness is when we talk about loudness
it's essentially how loud the bass can
get without distortion
that is the name of the game that is
what we're after
you know the perception on loudness for
your ears though is one two three
kilohertz and indeed
a hundred decibels at 3 kilohertz you
know you go insane i mean i'll just your
eardrums will blow for money or come out
the other
but 100 db at 20 hertz is 30 db above
noise floor above the threshold so
it just uh doesn't it's not an issue and
please please don't keep saying
go save your hearing i know uh nothing i
do
impacts my hearing you know this is this
is what i do and
and uh um uh as the uh
mythbusters used to say uh i'm uh
who you can call a professional so
i i know what i'm doing but really my
practice is not something that's
different than
than other people okay uh hopefully this
was uh useful to you and if you weren't
interested in the topic itself
and for me it'd be a great reference to
be able to provide to people
next time they tell me i'm listening to
love okay
uh see you in a future video bye-bye